yes guys my name is the chana welcome to
another one of these hazel dev vlogs
engine development so today I thought we
would be answering a fairly important
question ever since my channel has
gotten a little bit more attention
because of all of this like Unreal
Engine and he has five reaction videos
lots of new people have come in and
understandably have no idea what is
going on on this channel and to be
honest I'm not sure I do but I will try
my best to answer a very common question
which is why am i building a game engine
why in this day and age would I make a
game engine when there are so many good
game engines already out there there are
so many large teams like unity and
unreal building a massive technology
base that is very mature and has a lot
of talent and resources on it why would
I
a solar developer who's 25 years old
attempt to make a game engine and to be
honest it's a fair question and it's one
that I ask myself every day no I'm
joking for those of you who don't want
to watch this entire video which I
totally understand I'll give you the
short answer the short answer is because
I want true I don't know why but this
isn't answer that a lot of people don't
get because I see a lot of questions
asking me how I plan on making money
with hazel and the first thing that goes
through my head when I see a question
like that is why do I have to make money
with hazel why can't I just build this
thing because I enjoy making game
engines and I enjoy working on game
engines
I like making game engines more than I
like making games at least the kind of
software engineer aside the technical
side of games like that's fine but the
technical side of engines like I love
that that's my favorite thing to work on
when I want more of like a creative I
guess vibe or when I'm feeling like I'm
in a creative mood
that's when games interest me because
games to me it's like an interactive
piece of art I can make this whole like
3d or 2d world and environment with
characters in a story and you know
ambience and music and a whole
environment whole like a whole world you
know to explore and
you know make up a story and there's
this whole like creativity becomes with
it that you know I feel like an artist
when I'm working on something like that
and I am interested in various forms of
art and they're just like software
engineering and programming
I like making on I like making music
there's a lot of stuff that I like doing
and a game kind of brings all of that
together which is why I do really like
the idea of working on games as well but
in terms of the technical side of me I
like engines that's what I like and that
is why I'm building hazel not because
it's going to make me so much money and
I can't wait to like sell it to some
some you know investor or company who's
willing to pay twenty million dollars
for a lure that happened that probably
would do it let's be honest it's not
because I'm trying to get people to
subscribe for like five dollars a month
and that's how they you know get
accessed isn't that my patreon it's not
because I'm trying to get people to pay
royalties when they make a game with
Hayes or anything like that I think it
would be fairly foolish to try and
compete with unity and unreal I mean I'm
not sure why I'm not sure if anyone
actually thinks that I'm trying to do
that because I think that that's
ridiculous you know if you look at unity
or unreal they have like a team of
thousands well maybe hundreds of
engineers working full-time on like this
technology base for 15 years who most
probably a huge chunk of those engineers
are way more talented and good at what
they do than I am and I'm going to buy
myself try and compete with that that
seems that that just seems mad so step
one I'm building hazel because I want to
step two I'm not building it to compete
with unity or unreal I'm showing myself
building it on this YouTube channel as a
means of education I enjoy teaching
people I enjoy helping people and I
think that you know building a game
engine from scratch you know something
that's like cross-platform cross
rendering API whatever and has like a
set of tools and everything that's not
something that is taught very often like
there are tons of videos on how to make
games on YouTube and you know a good
chunk of them are good but when it comes
to building a game engine I feel like
this is something that is not as common
and that's why I'm trying to help out in
that area because I'm very interested in
that area
and I think I can contribute something
in that kind of in terms of like
educating people how to do that because
I have a fair bit of X of professional
experience and also it's kind of one of
my passions so why not help people and
teach that and also do what I love doing
and the final phase of this is because
eventually I do want to make a game with
hazel and publish it you know on
something like steam and sell it so
that's where the money-making side of
hazel might come in I guess but
ultimately I want to make a game with
hazel eventually this isn't something
that I'm rushing to do whatsoever it's
not like quick let's make a game and
release it on steam and make some money
that's if I was doing that I just use
unity or unreal it's about making
something from the ground up working on
something that I love which is a game
mentioned and then eventually using that
platform for intended purpose which is
to create some kind of creative
application out of it and that's
something like I mentioned that I was
working on a little game with my wife
that's you know at this at this stage is
just like you know ideas and we're just
kind of learning what kind of a style we
want I mean she's a fairly good artist
at least in my opinion but she hasn't
really had much experience with digital
mediums and when I say not much I mean
like literally none so we're kind of
learning about that together we
ultimately just want to make a game that
tells a story and that is immersive you
know with good ambience and good music
that I'll write and stuff like that and
so that game like to us kind of is you
know literally like a work of art like
an interactive work of art which tells a
story and I mean it's really early days
now like you know once there is
something to show that we might share
more with you but at the moment it's
it's super early days but the point is
you know eventually I do want to use
hazel to make a game that's kind of my
end term goal I mean even if I was not
interested in games or art at all I
probably still want to do something like
that because if you're building a
platform upon which to make applications
and games it'd be a good idea to
actually prove that is capable of doing
that by publishing a game and so that is
one of my my one of my major goals with
hazel so to summarize I'm a hey game
engine because I want to I'm making a
game engine to teach other people how to
make game engines be
I think that that's an in it's a very
useful skill that isn't taught very much
and I'm also making a game engine
because I want to eventually make a game
with it
so hopefully that sheds some light as to
why I'm doing this incredibly difficult
and potentially not worth it task with
my life hopefully I'm doing the right
thing if you are also building a game
engine then I'd love to know why you're
doing that leave a comment below and we
can kind of have a cute little
discussion with all the various people
who are interested in building game
engines and why they're doing that
because you know I have my own reasons
but I'm also curious as to why you might
be doing the same I want to emphasize
that even though I am I would say like
my primary profession has been a
programmer Lima Lima software engineer
even though that is the case I don't see
myself as a programmer I don't define
myself as hey I'm Yan Cheu knockoff I'm
a programmer I you know I as I mentioned
like especially I think in the Y lift EA
video which I'll link up there I see
myself as someone who's it's not that I
see myself I'm like I think I hate using
the word see myself because the term see
myself just picture I picture myself
just lying in bed being like hmm let's
think about myself and who I am which I
don't do but if I had to sit down here
and define myself as I said it wouldn't
be a programmer it's I'm interested in a
lot of different things I'm building a
platform that will enable me to be
creative in the future and that's like a
side of me that I think that I don't
share very much on the YouTube channel I
do have a little personal channel I'll
link it up there as well there's like
one live stream on it but in the future
I'm going to share myself like making
music on that you know doing a live
stream of me making music on that
channel and you know in the future maybe
I'll be you know streaming myself making
some art or something like that you know
it's not all about programming for me
and I definitely don't see myself as
just a programmer which is why you know
I think another huge reason that I'm
building hazel is because I have the
technical skills and because I'm
interested in the technical side of
things I guess I have a fairly rare
opportunity potentially to build my own
platform upon which I can then produce
odd and I think that's really cool it's
really special and I'm definitely really
blessed to be in a in a position where I
can just do this
my full-time job and I definitely
appreciate that and I appreciate all the
support from all of you lovely people so
thank you for watching this video I know
that this is like technically a game
engine devlog I don't really have too
much too short at the moment I'm kind of
in the thick of like trying to rewrite a
lot of the IM GUI UI code specifically
the way that hazel uses i'm going for
its level editor which is basically like
i mean ultimately what i'm trying to do
is just write a standardized way of
creating UI components and widgets and
all that stuff for hazelnut which is a
level editor in hazel and i'm also
refactoring like a lot of the ECS and
trying to get it so that it's fairly
easy to like create new entities delete
entities from the scene make new scenes
gonna start work on how to serialize
scenes into files as well so that we can
like save and load scenes and do all of
that stuff as well and yeah just UI for
like creating deleting entities and
adding components and linking that up to
scripts dynamically and doing all that
stuff so there's a lot of backend work
there's not much to show in the UI I
think most of its actually broken but
that's the update for the week and I
hope you guys enjoy these little hazel
dev logs if you do please don't forget
to hit the like button and help support
what I'm doing if you're interested in
that bug our patreon account for Ashley
Turner where you get access to weekly
live streams as well as all the source
code to hazel dev and all of that stuff
and and you'll be supporting everything
that I'm doing here on this channel so a
huge thank you to everyone who does that
I really do appreciate your support
thank you all for watching goodbye
[Music]
[Music]